the last white president of south africa
f w de klerk has died at the age of 85.
he freed the anc leader nelson mandela
from prison and
jointly with him was awarded later on
the nobel peace prize let's get the
thoughts of our africa correspondent
john sparks who joins me from
johannesburg so big figure in south
african history uh fw declared just how
is he going to be remembered
yeah he is a big figure and i think that
is the
that is the best question to ask right
now because i think his
his death will stimulate a whole lot of
debate but probably not a great deal of
of national sorrow or national
commiseration he he really was a very
controversial figure uh he came from a
prominent afrikaner family he vigorously
supported the system of racial
segregation in south africa which is
called or was called at the time
apartheid
um he rose up the ranks became the
president of south africa in 1989 and
then he he shocked the nation he shot
the party he shot the world
when he announced to parliament that he
would be
releasing nelson mandela a man who had
been jailed he was the leader of the
outlawed african national congress party
he lifted the ban on the anc as well and
it was a series of decisions that were
announced in 1990 in parliament that
really sort of kick-started
the transition the political transition
in south south africa that eventually
saw mandela voted as the first black
president in 1994 and through an
electoral process that saw blacks voting
for the very first time but his role in
that subject to a whole lot of debate i
don't think he's going to be celebrated
by that many people small smaller number
of white south africans
find him guilty of betrayal for handing
over power to the black majority who
they saw as unqualified
to rule i think for black south africans
i think a lot of them saw him as a
shrewd political figure at the time
someone who was playing political games
trying to prolong his his life in public
life in south africa i think a lot of
them think that his role in that has
been overwritten overplayed over
accredited by by people like us i was
speaking to an analyst just before i
came to speak to you called leiberhong
peco and she said to me look this man
was not an angel the power that he said
that he handed over to black south
africans was never his power to hand
over in the first place that power had
been taken by force from the black
people of south africa and he has left a
whole lot of questions that need to be
answered in the in the words of miss
peco where are the bodies where are the
documents where are the documents which
describe the crimes of the apartheid
regime a lot of people say we just
haven't seen evidence of who was
responsible and they hold
this man fw to clerk for many of those
crimes
all right john good to see you we'll
chat to you a little later thanks for
now